speaking of taxes i think you had this
exact debate with ben shapiro i remember
you're saying i don't think taxes should
be zero but i also don't think it should
be a hundred percent he was debating on
like yeah
in the reagan days it was ninety one
percent i think that's something
what's special what's your number your
what's the number you're saying so
patrick uh i used to be a republican and
so my dad left it started his dirt poor
southeastern turkey uh all a farmer
the reason part of the reason i'm
progressive today is because in turkey
back in the 1960s they had free college
education to anyone who could score at
the top okay so my dad and my uncle
worked their ass off to score at the top
of the of those college entrance exams
and without any money they got into the
he got in the best engineering school in
turkey then he set up his own company i
mean he is the american dream and i
interviewed him and conservatives loved
him right and they're like how did a
jackass like you come out of that guy
right
and so and i'll and it will go even
further my dad was basically chased out
of turkey by a communist so he had set
up a business and they were threatening
his life because he was a capitalist pig
okay now still we're progressive because
we have none of this if the government
did not provide a free college education
to my dad right now i'd be an all a
farmer in southeastern turkey a lot of
the right wings going ah
stayed there bro
so
um now having said that though um
why did i leave the republican party
because every part of it would turn out
to be marketing so like you talk about
the defense con
budget right do we need a strong
military of course we need a strong
military uh and so you can't have no
military that's nuts right but um
but do we need this level of monstrous
spending with no accountability where
they waste billion after billion because
it's not wasted it's going in the pocket
of defense contractor executives so the
correct answer is balance so that brings
us to taxes so
when
they had it at 91
right
then we were republicans and and reagan
came in it was still at 70
our family's still republicans right
nobody paid 91 by the way at the time
just so
nobody ever paid 91 there was so many
loopholes the average guy was paying 40
to 50 percent who was making money
because they so even though i get what
you're saying the 40 years of taxes
there's nobody that was paying 91 at the
time yeah and people have to understand
that that's above a certain number and
the number is super high
the famous story with reagan was that he
would make a hundred grand for each
movie and then after 200 grand that's
the time this is in the 40s whatever it
was anything over 200 grand it's a 91
he's like i'm not doing a third freaking
movie yeah i make nine percent of the
movie so he would just do two movies a
year and that was basically impetus for
his tax plan yeah so so there
is a point where taxes are too high
right
but right now we've lowered taxes 128
times i'm making that number up it's
hyperbole but it but probably if you
looked at the real number might be right
around that or more
we're constantly lowering taxes on rich
and most importantly corporations right
so and then they remember when they're
in the trump tax cut they were gonna do
two trillion dollars mainly for
corporations
what happened mr populist uh and then
they were supposed to take away the
loopholes what'd they do instead they
did two trillion dollars in taxes they
didn't take away a single loophole they
were lying all the time republicans were
lying democrats were lying none of them
took away a single goddamn loophole so
it was a two trillion dollar giveaway uh
to the richest people in the country and
to corporations so taxes should be
around
it should be layered right progressive
like reagan
so late well progressive taxes is
american like we've had progressive
taxation in america where would you put
the top line
you know above a billion dollars uh it
would it would be a it'd be a high
number i mean 50 percent at least above
a billion dollars in earnings or
earnings in earnings yeah earned income
you're not talking capital gains capital
gains i'd put it whatever is the normal
tax i think it's outrageous capital
gains is low okay yeah so okay so
interesting so there's a few things that
you know you just said that uh uh
uh uh i actually you know like when you
say corporations you know i can't
believe we you know we have the
corporation taxes because our
corporation tax were the lowest it was
the highest at 35 points nobody paid
that to your point you're right nobody
paid it but it was high because they
just kind of let the money flow and they
took it out by debt or dividends or in
different ways that they can avoid
paying that
35 and then i think trump brought it
down to 21 21 and then it's back up to
25 well they're going to move it up by
the
way
so that's exactly how they good got
packed up of republicans democrats
republicans bring it down from 35 21
biden comes and goes i'm going to bring
it back to 28. wait it wasn't at 28. it
was a 35. mainstream media doesn't say a
word about it right then manchester says
i don't want 28 i want 25. and then
biden says i am the bold leader who's
going to get it to you at 25. wait a
minute you guys just took 10 points off
the corporate tax rate by biden did that
under the obama administration by the
way bush passed massive tax cuts for the
rich but they couldn't make him
permanent because it was so unpopular
then obama gets into office has biden
negotiate with mitch mcconnell he makes
94 of the tax cuts for the rich
permanent
the democrats did that not the
republicans it was binding himself it
was such a terrible deal that other
conservative democrats were livid
they're like how could you give
mcconnell 94 percent of what he wanted
by that's why i say biden is
conservative binding will give
republicans anything they want 24 7.
they have too many stuff on biden if you
ask me but here's the other part you
know how every time they're like let's
send money to you know to people to help
them out and bail them out every time
they print their money and send money to
them what are your thoughts on sending
money to people hey here's a thousand
dollars
stimulus checks what's what what are
your thoughts on so every andrew yank
model even a ubm
it all depends on context it all depends
on the facts so
when we were in the middle of covid did
people need relief checks yes
so i supported that completely um
ubi has some issues including they take
away a lot of social services to be able
to do ubi and i don't love that concept
and
and so i you know and and progressives
are split about ubi there's a lot of
different thoughts on it and i'm sure
there's good progressives who love it
and would disagree with me but i think
just giving money is not the most
productive way of the government
handling if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]